foreign
[Music]
I hear the professionals look straight
to camera good afternoon this is Edward
Murrell ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferris welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show ladies and gentlemen
I have one of my favorite people in
front of me Kevin Kelly who's Kevin
Kelly Kevin Kelly helped launch and edit
Wired Magazine he has written for the
New York Times And The Wall Street
Journal among many other Publications he
is the author of the new book excellent
advice for living wisdom I wish I'd
known earlier I have a lot to say about
this book we will get into it other
books by Kevin Kelly include out of
control the 1994 Classic book on
decentralized immersion systems the
silver cord a graphic novel about robots
and Angels what technology wants a
robust theory of Technology Vanishing
Asia his 50-year project to photograph
The Disappearing cultures of Asia and
the inevitable understanding the 12
technological forces that will shape our
future and New York Times bestseller
Kevin is currently co-chair of the long
now Foundation which is building a clock
in a mountain that will tick for ten
thousand years of course
he also has a daily blog a weekly
podcast about Cool Tools and a Weekly
Newsletter recommendo a free one-page
list of six very brief recommendations
of cool stuff you can find that at
recommendo.com that is r e c o m e n d
o.com I was gonna say
r-e-c-o-m-e-n-do.com you get the idea so
recommender.com take a look he is also a
senior Maverick at wired and lives in
Pacifica California you can find him on
Twitter at Kevin to Kelly Kevin the
number two Kelly and all thanks Kevin at
kk.org Kevin nice to see you again Tim
is always a pleasure and just seeing you
makes me happy I'm so glad to be here I
saw you walk in I was chatting with with
Harley of Shopify earlier today and you
walked in and I saw you across the room
with your yellow baseball cap on doesn't
hide the beard though so I spotted you
and also just made me very happy to see
you I was thinking about that
and how how incredibly valuable that is
what a gift it is and I'm glad to be
seen and so
I'm so glad to be able to share with you
another time of exploring some ideas and
just see where they go
now ideas you're a man of ideas and I
thought for
comic relief
we might start with a list of possible
topics to discuss with Kevin Kelly I
just want to read these because people
who are perhaps not long-term listeners
may not have heard our previous
conversations and I believe the title I
used you did not choose this I chose it
for our first conversation was Kevin
Kelly the real life most interesting man
in the world something along those lines
yes and people may say what hyperbole
what is this nonsense but wait allow me
to list the possible topics and I ask
every guest to send possible bullets for
exploration so here we go and then I
will return to a few of these the most
popular thing I've ever written one
thousand true fans 2008 why we built a
clock that will tick for 10 000 years
inside a mountain I've had a daily block
for 20 years for five years of weekly
podcast at wired we invented the click
on Advertising Banner for the web next I
spent 11 years creating a huge graphic
novel about angels and robots released
on Kickstarter the silver chord we're
going to come back to that my failed
campaign to discover all the species of
life on Earth in 2003 I made a long bet
on the collapse of the global human
population by 2060. my Ted Talk on why
we should be optimistic in 10 minutes
the most important article I've ever
written my case against belief in an AI
Singularity my most recent piece in
wired extolling the glories of
generative AI engines of wow I
co-founded the hackers conference in
1984 still going my 50-year passion
project and this goes on weighing 30
pounds about Vanishing Asia I rode my
bike Across America twice once west to
east once north to south I make a piece
of art every day my biggest audience and
most of my fans are in China where I'm
known simply as KK I have a screen
credit for working with Spielberg on the
Sci-Fi concepts for Minority Report with
a friend I built a two-family house from
scratch cutting down the trees it goes
on and on and on right the story of my
religious conversion on This American
Life in 1997 I made a music video in
1969 12 years before MTV
so
lest people
it does sound ridiculous and thank God
I'm a specialist in the ridiculous so I
thought we would start with this bet so
in 2003 I met a long bet on the collapse
of the global human population by 2060.
so what is a long bet and which
direction did you bet were you betting
on or against and why so long bets is a
service that we set up at the long now
Foundation which I can explain a little
bit more about that which is meant to
encourage long-term thinking so we made
a place where we could have a long bet
meaning more than two years about some
social least significant wager and the
idea would be that there would be a
public that and you'd be accountable for
it and there'd be money involved in the
wager
and the idea was
to also require people to put the logic
of why they
were going in a certain direction and
that over time if you had enough of this
you could see which kinds of logic and
what kinds of thinking would win more
often
and
to get around the laws of betting at the
time which basically is illegal to make
it bet that's been kind of slowly
changing but we engineered a kind of a
hacker which you could make a donation
to
what you would use the money and the
money would go to the foundation the
non-profit of the person who won the bet
so my bet and by the way there are a lot
of people who bet on including Warren
Buffett I made a million dollar bet that
basically index funds would beat any
investment hedge fund
and he won
what his charity won
my bet about the population was that the
population of the world the global
population of the world
by 2060 I think it was 2060. would be
the same as it was at the time of the
bet
which is I think 2003
so the idea is is that we're coming up
to a peak of human population that would
then on the other side go down so you
very commonly see the chart of the
rising population
but it's interesting to me that you
never see what happens on the other side
and what happens on the other side as
far as we can tell is that it plummets
and that's because resource scarcity no
no education falling birth rates just
following birth rates because modern
people
on average are not having more than two
kids per couple fraternity is falling
all around the planet including right
now even in the U.S and everything that
we've tried we being humans have tried
collectively to counter that has not
worked Japan is famously losing the
total number of people not just having a
lower birth rate they actually have a
decline in population
but they're actually not the lowest
birth rate which is South Korea
and China is aging Mexico is aging
faster than the US so all the people
that have been coming from Mexico Mexico
will want to have come back at some
point
so it's a really significant change
and again it's possible that we could
use technology to change it maybe have
artificial wombs or who knows what but
right now for the average person they're
not inclined to have a lot of children
and the people who do have children
don't have enough to cover for those who
who don't in terms of the world
population you can have immigration
which is what the U.S has been doing all
along
basically stealing people from other
countries but that doesn't help you
globally so here's where it's the
problem
from a lot of environmental it's just as
good news because there's less people
who are consuming consumed sources but
throughout history we've always only had
Rising living standards with Rising
population really yes we have no
experience do you think those are causal
or correlated that's the question I
think there's obviously some feedback
loop where the more people you have the
more ideas you have the more wealth you
have and that allows you to have more
kids
but we don't know all we can say is we
have no experience in having living
standards with
a smaller population a smaller audience
a smaller Market every year
so what do you think of the implications
of this and
is 2060
at the just after the Apex will it have
been declining for a period of time when
is the projected Apex if if you have a
projection right so that's one of the
evidences is that this peak this keeps
moving closer right it's not static it's
not static but it also means that
they're sort of like well all the
Productions about the increasing
population that people were assuming and
built into some of these demographic
models are being revised all the time so
that Peak keeps moving closer and the
height of the peak the numbers
of actually how high it is is changing
and I think one of the things that's
really important to understand for us in
our society right now is that if you ask
any question
at the global level
the answer is we have no idea and the
one thing we have we know most about is
human population and I think our our
number our counting of that is probably
off by 10 plus or minus yeah and that's
the thing that we know the most about
globally but if you ask like how much
fresh water is there how much
electricity is being generated globally
the answer is is that we really don't
know we have a very poor view of us
globally partly because there's areas of
the world that are so undeveloped we
don't have very good I have some poor
view meaning we just have very
incomplete yes we don't have a global
census we don't have a global way of
viewing we have now satellites that can
help us see but they can't count
everything yeah and so I think what
we're doing as a species is moving into
this era will become a global we have a
global economy we have a global view a
global machine all the Internet
connected together and will act more
global and maybe increasingly some
Global governance but
we're not there yet and so even
something as Primal and essential
as as foundational as our population I
think we don't even know have you had
any exposure to or interaction with the
Santa Fe Institute I have not but I've
recently had conversations with a number
of people Bill Gurley and others who are
involved complex adaptive systems I'd
just be curious to know what your
exposure has been what your opinion is
so my first book was written about
basically the Santa Fe Institute so the
out of control was initiated by
conference I went to at Los Alamos and
Santa Fe was hosting one of the first
conferences and
I I would go down there and talk to all
the scientists this is in the late 80s
and that was the beginning of this sort
of a complex adaptive system view of the
world and so that's what out of control
is about is looking at that view and
saying you know
the way biology works and the way this
complex technology works are very
similar they have very similar Dynamics
because they're complex adaptive systems
and what we want to make with like the
internet
this is all it's penetrations that you
can kind of like think of spam as like
an invading virus that you have to you
can't eliminate but you have to treat it
like an immune system where you keep it
at Bay and so the adopting some of these
biological Dynamics and applying to
machines and allow the work and trying
to make robots in early AI again we're
modeling off of what was being learned
and often reported or
sponsored by the Santa Fe Institute and
that kind of approach to complex
adaptive systems so yes I think it's
incredibly important and for me it was a
transformative
framing of the complicated things was to
think of them in these terms and my
whole book was about the fact that the
world of the maid and the world of the
born basically the same the two faces of
the same kind of dynamic and so you can
look at how Meadows work
ecosystems and then you can look at the
internet which was just beginning
and now of course it's in full bloom and
you can see how social media they have
similar behaviors yeah and you can find
thing in one that you then find in the
other and surprising ways sort of Life
imitating art and art imitating life in
the sense that we think we have invented
gears and then we were like oh wait a
second actually there are insects that
use gears for types of jumping right how
Wild is that right so there's biomimicry
was the field which was you know kind of
using those as models for ideas and
Frameworks for trying to make mechanical
things and that only takes you so far I
mean that was the kind of maybe the
genius or the the Breakthrough in the
Wright brothers yeah which is like we
didn't make
flying machines by strapping Wings to
people but by flapping our wings it was
like you put a big Surfboard on it you
fly there's limits to it and right now
with the aisf there there's you know
there's lots of looking at the neurology
and of course we call them neural Nets
so there is a huge amount of influence
but what I'm saying is even maybe a
little stronger
which is that it isn't as if these
mechanical systems are imitating biology
I'm saying they actually have the same
dynamics that are powering biology or
powering the technium in the technology
I think we are quite close on that right
in the sense that both paths end up in
the same places
and I tend to agree Los Alamos is there
any particular reason they chose Los
Alamos
there were a lot of physicists left over
from the Manhattan Project who kind of
liked living there and Mary galman was
the prime mover he liked it and I think
he might have been instrumental in
finding the funding for and he was on
the chair for for a very long time they
had spaces to convene and Santa Fe was
close to Los Alamos that was the reason
why I was in Santa Fe got it I've been
revisiting some of Richard feynman's
writer and he might have been part of
that whole thing too I mean he was he
was there for sure
that I don't know but certainly that is
part of the reason I asked about Los
Alamos Solomon brand right so let's take
a hard left which is I think
going to be common in this conversation
and we will probably come back we will
almost certainly come back to AI but I
don't want to open that
exactly all right you spent 11 years
creating huge graphic novel about angels
and robots silver cord
I am you may or may not know this but
deeply interested in comic books and
collected for a very long time spent and
all of my allowance all of my work money
almost all of it on comics for a very
long period of time wanted to be a
penciler why did it take 11 years and
what did the process of translating your
thinking and writing to that form look
like what were that what were the steps
so I met a friend who actually
was actually comic book artist and had
done had published and wanted to do
another one and
I'd kind of always wanted to try my hand
out because I I thought that this was a
brilliant genre for communicating lots
of things and particularly if you're
interested in science fiction it was
sort of like to me a little better than
a novel because it had that kind of
immersive visualization which I love I'm
a very visual person but it wasn't so
detailed that you needed to make a movie
of it but we thought we could do both
and we thought that maybe we could write
something that would have some appeal be
making movies so we would try to write
it the script as if we were writing a
movie and so some of the other
associates that we had worked for
Pixar
some stories say Associates it sounds
like a law firm what do you mean well I
mean collaborators actually here's what
it was my friend and these other friends
all went to the same church okay we all
have the same church and there were
people who worked at Pixar and some
people who worked at ilm and so I had
this idea of doing this this book
or this the story and the story was the
premise of it was I was imagining that
there would be these interdimensional
beings we're calling them Angels they're
made out of light because they're
intangible
and that they would
look down on humans and weep when they
saw us because we were getting the ride
that they craved that embodiment and we
were squandering it
so that's the basic premise is that
there is this this realm and there's
these beings and they're awaiting their
turn to be embodied and they're looking
at us and what we're doing with it's
like you have the ultimate in blowing it
guys and you're blowing it it's like
what would I do I would I would smother
my face with mango juice and I would you
know if I could take a dive into the
ocean and swim underwater at home so
that was the premise of it and then the
the added part of it was that some of
these Angelic beings would try to cheat
by becoming embodied into robots
um
they wouldn't go through the traditional
preparation that you require of moral
guidance and whoever else you needed to
be before you're allowed to be in a
human but they were going to cheat by
coming into robots giving a few steps
skipping a few steps and that these
would be kind of unhinger Rogue because
they weren't so anyway that's the
premise so you have these angels and
robots and a graphic novel and we would
tell stories and the issue was I'd never
written fiction in my life yeah although
the Pixar people had they were from the
story side
and I couldn't draw to the level
necessary so we worked on it and the
reason why I took 11 years was we made
it way too big
instead of doing it like little 20 Page
things decided to do the whole thing
Lord of the Rings in one go exactly well
actually we gotta advance from Simon and
Schuster to do it and we
were late in delivering in the guy who
bought it left they wanted it back blah
blah blah occupational hazard
essentially right so it took us that
long just to finish and we actually
kick-started it to printed when you were
generating the story were you doing it
in effectively screenplay form yes it
was written as a screenplay script what
did you collectively and maybe it was
different person to person hope this
story would do
if anything it's a really good question
and that's the most important question
you always want to be asking yourself
when you're doing these what effect do
you want to have on people how do you
want them to feel after they're done
do you want them to change your behavior
and for me it was this idea of the
Genesis of it which was to
nudge people a little bit more to
take advantage of this special time that
we have to interact with each other this
is what you get by being embodied is
that there's far more influence
we can influence things through the
physical way that we can't when we're
intangible beings and that was the issue
that these
other dimensional beings had is that
they don't have as much influence it's
really hard for them to influence
because
having a body means that you can
influence things by interacting within
physically and that's very powerful and
experience things and experience things
right and so that's what it was it was a
it was an ode or a a nudge for people to
maybe appreciate their own lives meaning
literally their life much more than they
do
and take it Kevin Kelly you're good at
helping friends myself included to do
that IRL in real life too right through
experiences and we may come back to that
but first
the iconic 1000 true fans the most
popular thing you've ever written right
why do you think
that is the case and what would you
double down on or revise if you were to
take another
stab right at it today the honest answer
one of the reasons why it's right
we talk about why it's good and useful
and then why it's popular the reason why
it's popular is actually through you
the the fact that you included it in one
of your books
and that's sort of lifted it out of my
little Realm
the reason why maybe it kind of
resonates with people
is because there is sort of a an
assumption
that
the goal is to hit it big The Big Time
Best Seller a hit and most people kind
of come to associate that those numbers
that kind of large scale with success
and the idea that success could look
differently that you could have a more
modest size
scale and that be successful
sometimes it's dismissed as lifestyle
businesses or whatever and
I kind of realize that the technology
would allow a different version of that
it was possible and that it would be
good it would be good for people and so
that was I think people can resonate
with that because it's
it's a viable alternative option to
things that was not spoken before was
not even really on the radar and when I
wrote it when I first wrote it before
you even saw it there was no Kickstarter
there was no Patron and I was challenged
with people like Journal near
to say we know that's a nice Theory but
there isn't any evidence that this is
actually working
and it was actually at that time I did a
follow-through and I tried to find
evidence and there was there was
evidence of established artists
from publishing or music or Studios who
had already an audience and could move
off of that to their own
but there wasn't any evidence of an
indigenous
organic growth from nothing
now there is every day people write to
me and meet me say yes I have been able
to do that
inspired someone by hearing of that
possibility
is there anything that you would modify
in that piece
or emphasize more so I did a
modification for you which was I talked
about the fact that one again one
benefit and one disadvantage the one
benefit is is that
part of what we're doing is
for all you need is a thousand true fans
then even if your interests are one in a
million
given the population of the Earth
of billions of people that means there's
a thousand people potentially
on the planet who will share your
interests if your interests are only one
in a million people that you still have
enough
and then the second thing was that just
to emphasize to people that
this is not for everybody that tending
the fans and interacting with them
is almost like a halftime job at least
maybe even more and not everybody's
suited to do that an artist might just
want to paint they don't want to deal
with fans and we see more of dealing
with fans what it means is it's not
always pretty and it can burn you out
and so I just want to emphasize that
this is an option and you don't have to
go all the way you can have your
thousand true fans and then you can have
lots of other casual fans and other fans
which would allow you to have other
people help you so it's not just you and
then secondly for some people you want
to have intermediaries it's just not
something do you want to spend your time
doing and that's perfectly fine but it's
a really great place to be able to start
from
so maybe you don't want to land there
but that's one of my pieces of advice is
that where you start it's not where
you're going to land so you this is a
good place to start that's exactly what
I was going to say which is even if you
want to hypothetically build a huge
company and change the world although
I'm very skeptical of people who lead
with that
I think most businesses fundamentally
are lifestyle businesses if you really
double click and look at it closely
enough even if someone aims to be a
Fortune 500 CEO in any case the point I
want to make is even if you have these
very lofty
large-scale goals beginning with the
exercise of reading 1000 true fans
and at least considering what your
approach would be to accomplish that
first is a great yeah fundamental step
and partly that is because you get a
thousand two fans by accumulating them
one by one and if you're focused on like
today I'm gonna get one more additional
customer
that is tremendously powerful you know
customer by customer are they happy am I
giving value to them
you know if you can focus on that that
is incredibly a superpower yeah for sure
and if you can take those 1000 true fans
in right and some subset of them become
your PR marketing forces then things can
multiply very quickly
I promise left turns we're gonna take
another left turn your failed campaign
to discover all the species of life on
Earth so I wanted to hit the highlight
and maybe this is also a highlight but I
would love for you to expand yeah on
this Lessons Learned what happened
so there was a conversation I was part
of
and I was sitting
next to a billionaire who said you know
it's actually
hard to give away a billion dollars
and for some reason I thought at that
moment I thought
well actually I know what I would do
and that would be I would hire all the
local indigenous people and have them be
barefoot taxonomists and go out and
discover and count or you know catalog
of all the living species on this planet
because we never done that and by the
way if we found life on another planet
that's the first thing we would do is a
systematic survey
of all the life on that planet but we
haven't done that on our own home planet
and because you're paying locals you
would distribute that money down really
really fast and Stewart brand was
sitting next to me and we kind of
thought it was a cool idea and then I
didn't think anything more of it because
I have ideas every I have a lot of ideas
I'm giving them away and then like a
week later Stuart said
let's do that idea and I said what I did
I'd forgotten it about it already I said
you know the idea at dinner about
counting all the species
I said yeah I you know I don't know it's
like I'm not taxonomist I'm a biologist
and Stewart's hunch was that with new
technology this was my bias too we might
be able to do that
in addition to it can we pause for just
a quick second could you just briefly
explain for people who don't know
booster yeah so Stuart brand is closer
and and the person who first hired me he
was he invented the whole earth catalog
in the 1969 and the best way to try the
Hall of catalog is it was kind of like
your information Guide to the world
before there was the internet and Steve
Jobs famously called it the internet
before there wasn't interesting it was
internet printed on newsprint because it
was it was reader generated so before
YouTube before anything if you wanted to
find out how to build a house or repair
your VW bug or start a homeschool or
keep ease where would you go there there
was literally no place to find an
information libraries didn't have that
information
there was no internet to look it up but
the whole earth catalog started to
accumulate those and there was readers
of it would send in their version it's
like oh the best book on gold panning is
this thing and then Stewart would run it
print it and run it right away and there
was no advertising it was kind of reader
supported
so that was Stuart Brandon he went on to
do things we started the well together
which was the first online access to the
internet and other things
so he's
my hero and he just had a recent book a
biography written about him by John
Markoff the New York Times Tech writer
so anyway Stewart has been sort of at
the center we're at the Leading Edge of
almost first the hippies the beatniks
and the hippies and then the digital
Forest Gump
he's kind of always there and his
background was biology he was a
biologist for a study with Paul Ehrlich
who is the population bomb guy on the
other side of this argument about
population so Stewart was sitting there
it was along now store
started alone now with me and Danny
Hillis and Peter Schwartz to think about
to encourage long-term thinking to be a
good ancestor how do we be good
ancestors
and at that dinner Stuart said later on
he said we should really try and do this
it would be kind of a great thing so we
actually started a foundation called all
species I named it all species inventory
all species foundation and
we were going to try and raise money
not from the usual sources that funded
taxonomy we didn't want to take any
money from that because it was really
pitiful the amount of money but to find
it from the Silicon Valley and get money
for developing the technology that would
be able to do that
and it was just too early it was just
too early too early in what respects
well right now on my phone I have Merlin
which will identify a bird song I have I
seek which will identify almost any
plant or mushroom that's what we needed
I see technologically yes and you needed
it because
even those those aren't going to
identify a new one if you have an app
that can identify the known ones then
you're only going to bother the
taxonomists with one that isn't
identified so right now otherwise people
are just sending the Bible oh this is a
brand new species replication is not a
new one don't bother me with that one so
that's what we needed and we were just
25 years too early in terms of
Technology being available to be able to
assist this and so it became kind of a
catalog of existing
species and that was the thing that
shocked us
was okay well first we need is we need a
list of all the existing species this is
whatever this is 2008 or something there
isn't one
it was like what
well there's all these taxonomics
Publications that are all buried in
these obscure
Publications that haven't been digitized
yet it's like so I was like oh my gosh
this is even further behind than we
thought so
that is sort of what it became it became
kind of a program just to digitize the
existing
known species and then the other thing
is that as they started to do that they
realized that there was this huge
duplication
of species having more than one name
because they're being you know somebody
in Germany and somebody in Japan and not
even knowing that they're talking about
the same thing so it was failed in the
sense that we still don't know
all the species on this planet
we don't even know how many we don't
know
and we're still only beginning to have a
central
integrated comprehensive complete
catalog of what we do know
and it's called the Encyclopedia of life
and EO Wilson before he died was
involved in that the legendary EO was
right
Mr consilience yes
Stuart Brandt let's spend a little more
time on Stewart brand who who's been a
guest on your show has been a guest he's
spectacular he is what would you see
what would you say his ages now he's 80
six maybe something like that and I
interviewed him not that long ago and he
was doing CrossFit two or three times a
week exactly and also military
background you just have to read his bio
to even begin to try to believe it so he
would he would be also maybe on your
short list for real world most
interesting yeah exactly
now I recall chatting with Stuart I
believe
about
resurrection of species so the potential
of Jurassic Park Style
resurrecting say woolly mammoths and
reintroducing some of these large
terrestrial herbivores for any host of
reasons
what do you think the future holds for
those types of plans yeah so if Stuart
Ryan feeling and I who did all species
and Stuart and Ryan went on to do revive
and restore is the name of their program
and it is to
originally the totem animal was the
mammoth The Woolly Mammoth was to bring
that back and there are a lot of very
interesting reasons why to do that and
the way that they do is basically to
take existing
Asian elephants and winterizing them
through breeding I got an accelerated
reading so if you're not just kind of
like hatch out of a of a test tube a
brand new woolly mammoth there would be
a sense in which you would kind of use
the line of existing elephants to try
and reverse kind of engineer them you
take a mendelian sort of approach too
but that's a little bit longer term and
actually Stewart and I went to in George
Church went to Siberia to go get samples
of the mammoths that were being exposed
by the thawing permafrost wow to get the
DNA from the trunk Jurassic Park seven
scene one right right opening exactly so
that was quite an experience
but there are other animals that are
that are closer to being able to they're
going to be a little bit easier to do it
wow all right well
optimism
you're one of the most optimistic people
I know mm-hmm
I think that that is a great influence
on me and the world and I sometimes push
back yes on some of it of course
we should yeah
what would be your doesn't have to be an
elevator pitch it could just be a very
long elevator run because we have
infinite time 38 floors yeah exactly
that's right moving as as slowly as you
would like
what is the argument for why we should
be optimistic
so generally people see optimism as kind
of a temperament Sunny View and I think
there is some of that and I have a
natural amount of it but over time I've
actually become even more optimistic
than my general tendency deliberately
it's kind of like a learned optimism and
I think the reason we should be as
optimistic as we can is because
it is how we make really good
things good complicated things so it's
hard enough
well I mean it's very hard to make good
complicated things work because
generally there's more way things can
fail than they can succeed and
it's very unlikely that we're going to
make
something really good that's complicated
inadvertently
they're hard to do so we have to
kind of see it and believe that it can
be done and that is where the optimism
comes in is envisioning something and
then believing that you could make it
real
because when we look back on history and
that's where a lot of my optimism comes
we realize that most of the things that
we have
now have been made by people who are
optimistic reviewing that there was
possible to make them and believe that
they were going to make them and could
imagine them so I think of it as a work
of imagination where you kind of Imagine
a good scenario
which is harder to do than imagining a
scenario where it fails or collapses it
is much easier to imagine how things
break
than it is to see how they work
and that's why entrepreneurs and all the
others are rightly lauded because
they're going against that grain it's it
is hard to imagine how we could have
this thing that seems like it is
improbable and most things that work are
improbable that's the definition from
the Santa Fe complexity theory is that
things breaking down is the probable
complicated things working are
improbable by definition and so you're
against the improbable and that work of
Imagining the improbable and having the
improbable
succeed
in believing it can is optimism which
means that the optimists are the ones
who shape our future so I'd like to give
a little story of a car
and you need to have breaks on the car
to steer the car yeah
I'm with you so far
but the engine is actually the more
important element and so there are
people in our there are organizations
and there are methods that are going to
be doing the breaking
and I think they're essential I want
breaks in the car but I just feel that
the break can overwhelm in crosstalk
nation in that we also want to remember
to focus on making the engine even
stronger
so I emphasize the engine
so I want to take a closer look at the
engine so if things breaking down are
the probable and there are many
more ways things can go wrong then they
can go right right
if I'm hearing you correctly
and maybe also bringing in some of my
own
position it would be that active
optimism is probably more valuable than
passive optimism
the beliefs that you can make things
turn out all right as opposed to the
belief that things will turn out all
right and therefore
I can go about my day
and not concern myself with worries
about ABCD e all the way through Z and
I'm curious if you suddenly had the
Kevin Kelly Institute for
active optimists
how you would cultivate this or
maybe encourage it in more people
because I do see
optimists who are
not panicked not necessarily paranoid
but they are
very interested and excited and feel
some moral obligation to focus on
solving really high leverage problems or
creating new technologies
I also see techno optimists right well
if a b and c gets bad enough if the
temperature of the earth gets to X Y and
Z then we'll have these Technologies and
all be fine and if this happens then
that'll all be fine and you know people
thought oil was going to run out by this
year but they didn't factor in that as
the number of barrels per year produced
went down the price would go up and then
all these other Technologies like
fracking became viable and voila no
problem I view those camps as somewhat
different and I'm just wondering if you
have any perspectives on that I love
your distinction between passive
optimism and active I think that's
brilliant and right on and but the
reality is is that you can't be active
about everything you have to kind of
Select tone choose and so there is a
sense in which okay
there is a greater than zero chance that
the Earth could be impacted by an
asteroid right and it would be really
devastating among the most devastating
things that could ever happen to this
planet far beyond even when climate
change sure
it would definitely change the climate
exactly and very fast so it's really
good that there is now a group of people
who are thinking about that and there's
you know the b1612 foundation which is
just tracking all the asteroids what was
it called b1612 after The Little Prince
okay right got it and it's a viable
thing that they've been they've been
behind all the tracking of all the
asteroids and kind of upping that and
then you know recently we just actually
sent something that hit the asteroid and
deflected it so it's the first Cosmic
impact you really had you know in the
cosmos pretty wild to think like the
monkeys on spinning around exactly right
figured out how to deflect so it's good
that there is a small group of people
but we don't need to to have that be our
concern for making National policy every
year I mean we're not that probability
is so low sure that shouldn't really be
a factor in us making our decisions
about what we're going to do this year
so that's passive in that sense I mean
we I can be passive about because there
is another group of people that is
active and you know that a group is
active right so one of the major
things for me was the more I thought
about the future the more I became
interested in history and the more I
read history
the more the reality of progress
became and I think just acknowledging
the reality of progress would go a large
huge step in helping our optimism now
I'm interrupting not to push back but
just for definition of terms what do you
mean by progress because that word can
be used to mean a lot of different
things that's right it's a very loaded
word and
I'm using it to mean simply that
Angel's number better nature type stuff
yes
how to say it's
it means that overall on average
this is a better place to live than any
time in the past and this is the kind of
Obama test I don't know if you heard
about that but it's like if you were to
be born randomly in any time period
it could be male female poor Rich you
totally at random on some average thing
what time do you want to live in what
time period and like there's no way you
would want to be anything before at
least 50 years ago and maybe not even
within 50 years and so
because we intuitively understand that
this is actually the best time to be
alive but there is a recognition of like
what are the currents that made that
what has allowed that what's what's
operating is it still going and from my
view of history and I had the chance to
live in the past and on a time machine
we will talk about that in a minute okay
wow I didn't see that coming yes okay
time I'm taking a time machine I have
I've been in the time machine and it's
very very clear that we've been on a
momentum in a in a trajectory of
progress and it's possible
that could stop tomorrow
it's highly unlikely that it's going to
stop tomorrow so there is just all the
conditions that make that suggest that
it will continue and so
part of our optimism can come from that
okay
time machine's coming up yeah I want
people to stick around right after this
commercial breaks no I'm not going to
take commercial break but I do
want to ask you given the bet
on collapse of yeah Global human
population do you think that
by 2060. if we've peaked out at the top
of the roller coaster do you think this
progress is inextricably linked to
population growth and population density
and if that's the case do you think
we might be looking at regression
not trying to turn into the dark side
you're asking the exact right questions
you know there's a movement called
degrowth the degrowth movement I'm not
familiar so these are people who
basically see the
Troubles of the world and particularly
climate when coming from our addiction
to growth growth is kind of the consumer
capitalistic kind of idea that they grow
grow grow and they're saying
it's finite you can't continue to grow
and we have to
degrowth stop growing
there's a little bit of a confusion in
English because there's two meaning of
the word growth there is growth to add
more more pounds to add more and more
stuff to get bigger wider heavier
to have more things to sell more
refrigerators to sell more bottles of
wine
but there's another meaning of the word
growth which is probably closer to what
you're interested in personal growth
development maturing our knowledge
groups knowledge growth I guess in a
sense it's the same as the first but
it's no it's increasing this complexity
it's taking the same number of atoms and
having a more complex Arrangement it's
going from a jellyfish to a
chimpanzee or something and so that
complex adaptive system where you have
increasing levels of complexity and
more exotropy in it that is a different
kind of growth what is exotropia I know
what entropy is it's the opposite cell
like exoskeleton the definition of
entropy
right is
increasing disorder and there's
something called negative
entropy which is what I'm talking about
but that's a double negative I don't
like double negatives so exotropy
is basically an increase in order I got
it all right and that's that negative
entropy which is what this used in the
Santa Fe
isotope yeah so exotropy is this idea of
this increasing order that comes at the
cost of increasing entropy so that's the
thing so you get your system like a
living cell
is actually increasing the generation of
entropy as it increases this order it's
like a magnifying glass with the sun
you've ever seen that yeah there's a
little bright spot in the middle of a
lens with a in the Sun but all around it
is a shadow it's just taking all the
light right and concentrating
concentrated in so it generates a shadow
right so they go together
they go together so what type of growth
is an increase in complexity so you have
an economy where instead of trying to
sell more bottles of wine you try to
sell the same number of wines but better
wine
okay that's
different kind of growth that's the kind
of growth that we can shift into
we're just increasing the quality of
things do you think they're incentives
that will drive that
well the decreasing population
how are we going to keep our Revenue
numbers the same Well everybody's
leaving right you have a smaller Market
every year a smaller audience so one way
is to make things better to make better
stuff yeah and we have so refrigerators
you know if you just count how many
refrigerators are being sold yeah you
can have increasing numbers but you
could sell refrigerators and make them
better every year which is what we've
been doing and that's actually not often
accounted for in in economics
it's just like his GDP is how many
refrigerators per unit are you making
but they're not saying well we actually
these new refrigerators are better
because they use less energy they make
ice as well as refrigerate they you know
they do all these other things that's
not really accounted for and so we can
change how we account for things we
start to measure something different
just other than
expansion the more the more stuff so we
need some new metrics so yes I am
optimistic that we can change
are understanding and what we aim for
it's not inevitable though yeah
well time will tell and makes me want to
be a better student of History also as
you pointed out so the time machine time
machine I know you're going to ask about
how it's there it's right there top
right time machine question mark for
those who think I'm lying
a time machine I took like a 20 bus ride
in Northern Afghanistan
in
1975 somewhere
and I arrived in a different Century
literally in a different century
I had no map I'd not anybody had heard
of anybody who ever went there I mean
there was obviously lots of Afghans but
I mean no no tourists I had no idea if I
could get there
it was literally a name on a very poor
map and how did you choose it because
it's like coming to America just it was
so remote and I wanted to see what was
at the end of the line and here was a
town I don't know how you know maybe
there's a hundred thousand people in
this town that's a good size a good
sized town
there was no electricity
in the town
they didn't have street lights they
would have a guy at night go and light
kerosene lamps the street lighter
they would throw their into the
street
I mean out the window kind of stuff it
was like
and of course the feudal there's a
feudal structure I mean they had
basically slaves and child brides and
the whole thing it was just medieval in
every way very little metal there's no
signage on the town there was no science
didn't need sign
it was like I'm in a different century
I'm in a different century and that
experience of
of seeing what you get when you have
development in technology and of course
you can see all the challenges and
problems but the main thing that I
learned from that experience is thing
that we get is we get choices and
options that's ultimately what we get
from the technology so the people
growing up there their occupations were
were faded or doesn't if you're male
you're going to be a farmer maybe a
blacksmith sure a woman you're going to
be a wife and a mother and that was it
if you took the bus all the way into the
City and went somewhere else you'd be in
a grimy gritty slum but you had a choice
for the first time of what you could do
and maybe not then but now if you took
that best ride you might be a web
designer of yoga teacher mortgage broker
whatever you have choices and that's
what they did not have they had very
strong family good identity tremendous
support maybe organic food
but no choices
AI
from the 15th century to today
even as I understand it some
let's call them AI researchers computer
scientists with familiarity with AI
couldn't have even predicted several
years ago us having today right many
choices maybe some difficult choices
maybe some difficult outcomes I might go
so far to say and
I wanted to read something this is from
your wired piece November 2022 mm-hmm
and this is after spending months
creating thousands of images using AI
excellent peace
I think it Limitless creativity yeah and
there's one line that stuck out to me
and I was like man that's a strong
statement I kind of wish Kevin hadn't
included this because I think it's going
to be hard to defend and I would like to
talk about it sure and this also pairs
with an article I only started recently
reading from Mark Andreessen and as I
understand the basic premise is that AI
will not cause an increase in
unemployment which is a bit broader than
the line that we have here so let me
read
I've spent the last six months using AIS
to create thousands of striking images
often losing a night's sleep in the
unended quest to find just one more
Beauty hidden in the code and after
interviewing the Creator's power users
and other early adopters into generators
I can make a very clear prediction
generative AI will alter how we design
just about everything period
side note I completely agree with this
oh and not a single human artist will
lose their job because of this new
technology so maybe I should ask you to
clarify this
because I work with tons and tons and
tons of contractors
and there are artists right now I've
worked with who are going to be replaced
at least some of their functions will be
replaced by AI so I would predict they
will lose that specific job not
necessarily with me but at some point in
the next few years they will probably
lose that job if they have adapted to
using the Technologies I think
or carved a niche for themselves they
will find another job but they will lose
jobs so how would you expand on this
statement there might be a little bit of
semantics here because I I would say
that there will replace many tasks but
not their job okay
so this is what AR does we replace tasks
there are tasks that we do most jobs are
complex of different tasks a lot of
these tasks will go to the AI but not
necessarily the job okay so the job will
shift and you'll have different tasks
part of that strength is that I would
actually maybe even expand this even
broader and people in a welcome feedback
on this my claim would be that I don't
think there's anybody in any field
that's lost their job because of AI so
far
um
there's tasks that have gone away but
not jobs and
a lot of the worry about this AI is what
I call third person worry
they're saying my job hobby I'm not
going to be replaced but I can imagine
some somebody else or maybe I can
imagine my friend losing it but but I'm
still waiting for someone to say I lost
my job a real person with a real name
who lost their job because of AI and so
far
I haven't I've maybe even offer like a
200 Bounty if you can tell me the name
specific person who lost her job because
of AI of any sort
and it's because
yeah why take such a binary
bet I know you like these guys I would
take the opposite side of that thing but
please continue well you can take it by
giving a name I just have to fire some
money
but you're at the AI That's what I'm
saying because of AI well I would have
to replace them with AI and then I can
blame it on AI right okay and you won't
be able to do that right now okay
let's take an example if I may yes logo
design yes that is what somebody does
day in day out right they design logo
right and I had gone to some of the
local designers AI local there are logo
AI designers right now and they're
amazing
but here's the position this is my
position is what we get from these AIS
currently right now are Universal
personal interns or intern they're doing
the work of interns UPS upis okay and
they're really amazing
but you have to check their work
it's embarrassing to release
their work
without Improvement the intern work yeah
so I've used these logo AI generators
and I'll work with them over and over
again and this is what the artists will
be doing the artist is going to be
working with their interns generating
all these possibilities tweaking them
they're kind of like a director or
conductor they're managing the interns
and they're not releasing the intern
work
unedited unpolished uncurated
that's what their new tasks become
the artists
I'm not totally convinced however I
think that will happen but I I do think
some Rank and file will perhaps need to
find new jobs at the very least if
someone has AI
as the UPI I would imagine if you have a
brand Design Studio that focuses on
logos with 30 employees some of which
are junior there might be some Shuffle
but we can go ahead I mean there's going
to be a lot of art generated from these
entities these AIS and I always want to
say plural always plural there's not one
AI there's AIS all different species
but most of that work is being used for
areas that are blank now where there is
no pictures where there isn't anything
so I have
my assistant actually has for years
woken up in the middle of night to write
her dreams down
and now she feeds those dreams into the
air and she illustrates them and they're
just amazing there were no illustrations
before now they're illustrations yep I
use them to generate images for my
slides there were no pictures before now
there are pictures so it's not like I'm
replacing somebody it's not a zero
filling it in yeah and by the way
there's about 30 million
brand new never seen before images
generated every day
with these image generators 30 million
and I would say about maybe 95 or maybe
98 of them there's an audience of one
mm-hmm
it's for the pure pleasure
of seeing this it's like it's like you
would take a walk out into the into
nature and just see a beautiful scene
it's like I'm just enjoying this this is
why they're mostly being generated yeah
the predominant number of them just
because they're beautiful
okay and so they weren't there before
that you could not have your own private
Museum of these really cool images maybe
no one will ever see again yeah okay and
so
that's what they're being mostly used
for is filling in the blank spaces and
that's also true again of a lot of the
other intern work that may be writing
things that nobody else but the boss
sees yeah
let's look at this a little more closely
so
I will say just as a means of setting
the table I'm deeply deeply interested
in these tools which is why and the
effects that they will have on
the creative economies the economy
period broadly speaking Society
I think they're very underestimated
and I'd love to get your take on that in
a bit
I've run AI art competitions related to
some of the fiction that I put out and
have been absolutely Blown Away
I also
sympathize with some artists say on
artstation or deviantART who are part of
the training set who are popularly
mimicked right so prompt
and I can understand why these artists
would be upset feel threatened maybe be
financially impacted I imagine their
commissioned work might be
how do you think that'll shake out and I
know based on some of the conversations
that we've had that
I believe your perspective is if if
people are relevant they're going to be
copied anyway right and if they're not
it doesn't really matter if they're in
the training data right something along
those lines
so Picasso's influence is going to be
seen all over the place no matter what
but how do you think this will shake out
in the next handful of years because I
understand why people would have an
aversion as artists I think there will
be
people
companies who make training sets they're
all opt-in in some capacity maybe most
of it's sort of you know already out of
copyright
and they'll be sold as green watches
ethical
you know training sets whatever it is
fair trade AI artwork exactly and
there could be a lot of them where
people will use it they'll train the
things on their own work
like help me make more images in my
style I am doing some experience with
that right now exactly and there's going
to be this ability over time to require
less of a training set for right now we
can only way we train these is the more
the billions the better but
human toddler can learn
the difference between a cat and a dog
just with 12 examples and when we start
to have more targeted like that I think
people will start to clamor to be
included in the training set what needs
to happen for the AIS to require far
fewer examples in these these training
data sets we don't know
that's the short answer but we suspect
it's distance proof because we have time
so many
but it may require right now there's
kind of the Brute Force these neural
Nets Brute Force meaning that they're
very flat and they didn't work in the
beginning because they weren't big
enough and the bigger we make them
they seem to overcome a lot of the
problems
but it's really clear to most people
that we can't get all the way to where
we want to go
just with these flat because these
models basically they do one and a half
things they do pattern recognition and
pattern generation that's all they don't
do symbolic logic inductive reasoning
the current ones aren't capable of that
ironing tough irony and so it's just
amazing that they have gone as far as
they have and we keep expecting that
they can't go any further but they keep
surprising us
but we're pretty sure that they can't go
all the way and the example I would use
is like Wikipedia
Wikipedia is a flat the idea was the
flat it comes up from the bottom if it's
bottom up
it's like how far can you make it
reliable encyclopedia just from the
bottom up well a lot farther than you
initially thought but we also know that
Wikipedia has succeeded because in
recent years have been more top-down
control of the editors and you have to
have for ultimately what you want a
combination of mostly bottom up that's
somewhat regulated by some top-down
control editorial control all that kind
of stuff and that's what we don't really
have in AI right now we have just the
bottom up
it's very very bottom up and there's
just the suspicion looking at kind of
the Santa Fe work on complex adaptive
systems that you'll want to have some
top-down governance to assist
this bottom up to get where you want to
go you've interviewed just about
everybody I mean you can you can get to
just about everybody and I know you've
spoken to the who's who of AI and any
adjacent field that you want to
investigate you're very you know a lot
of people and you know a lot of people
who know a lot of people so you've
you've spoken to so many
and you have I would say one of the more
impressive
you know Nostradamus like
predictive track records
what would be your predictions
speculations for the next
within the next five to ten years could
be a shorter time frame of what you
think in AI yeah
here's what I expect
the thing I want to emphasize is that
there's plural there's AIS so this idea
of the monolithic AI taking over they're
just they're like machines and they're
they follow the general engineering
Maxim which is that you cannot optimize
everything there's always trade-offs so
we're going to engineer these AIS to be
good for certain things but not as good
as something else in another dimension
and we already see that with say the
image generators some favorite artists
some favorite photography there'll be
different personalities the one that
does painting the best probably isn't
going to be the best for writing
there'll be some kind of transformative
pretty bad at hands and so I say the
general stance we're going to have is
what I call dumbs Martin
okay there'd be really smart and is that
Pennsylvania Dutch well I don't know
it's kind of like that it's Amish Martin
we're just going to be furious it's like
how could you be so dumb when you're so
smart about these other things this is
going to be their typical reaction it's
like you're insanely brilliant but
you're so dumb here sounds like half of
Silicon Valley exactly and I'm smart
it'll be more and more difficult to kind
of generalize but what I'm saying is
that they're going to be engineered for
specific tasks primarily and there will
be a general one but the general one
would be kind of like like the Swiss
army knife yeah you know it's like good
generally but not really the best in any
one tool yeah that's the engineering
Maxim so we should expect multiple
varieties of these
and for me the best stance is to think
of them as artificial aliens okay aliens
means they could be like Spock or yoded
very very smart but they
they're just doing things differently
than we were doing if they have a sense
of humor it'll be a little off
but that is actually their benefit
because they help us think different and
that's what we're going to be using them
for that's what people are already using
for is generate ideas like there's
probably an idea that no human would
ever have come up with and that helps me
come up with a new idea
the third thing I would say about the
AIS is that most of them will be unseen
they'll be behind the Office operating
things the plumbing the infrastructure
and that's actually a sign of their
success
technology succeed when we don't see
them anymore we don't think about them
they become boring
and that the majority of the stuff won't
even be outward facing it'll be just
behind the scenes and
and then this idea of consciousness
Consciousness is a liability
you don't want your car to be conscious
you want to drive don't want to be
worrying about whether it should major
in finance you want it to focus on the
road so there will be advertising AIS as
conscious free dumb and obedience yes
exactly extra thirty dollars per month
exactly so I would say a couple things
one is I think AI overall is under hyped
but the current version we won't even
call AI in 30 years we'll look back and
that's that wasn't it and so it means
that there's no AI experts right now
but in the short time we're probably
overestimating this idea like
Advanced unemployment stuff not in the
next couple of years for sure so
everything you've said makes sense tools
will get specialized
they will become so embedded that we
will cease to think about them hopefully
and hopefully right in the same way that
you waved at the lights you know we have
all sorts of Lights in here but
it's not like we walk into any room with
artificial light and we think
good Lord what is this miracle of
engineering right right and human
ingenuity
I think most folks be like okay okay so
why is it under hyped right what what
should surprise people or what what are
people not appreciating
so I was involved with the internet I
was living online for at least 10 years
before 1992-93 when wire started
and in a certain sense it's like
we couldn't get anybody to take it
seriously it was dismissed as teenage
boys stuff and it was kind of that's
what it was but
I felt like no this is like this is
really significant this is really
powerful and what changed it was an
interface change it became visual for
the first time in the web was pictures
and stuff and that's when everybody
Switched at it most of the AI happening
today has been happening with all these
chap has been happening for years what's
new is we now have an interface we have
the conversational it's this idea of the
large language model we have a
conversational interface and that
suddenly was like
the power that's been there for years is
now suddenly accessible it's like having
the pictures on the web
and so we're suddenly thinking about it
something in people's faces in the same
way the internet was completely Fringe
and then when the web came along it very
rapidly
became mainstream I remember the first
time I saw my
gas station the pump there was like a
URL I was like oh my gosh this is like
it's here this is I have the same
feeling right now happening with the
chatbots in the and the image generator
says these capabilities have been around
for at least a decade but now what's new
is we have a
a language interface a conversational
interface with them and the powers is
sort of completely in our faces now and
so where do we go from there I think we
are going to then start to apply this to
everything right it's going to be I mean
as we speak every day there's people
embedding this and they're going to
embed it with this interface so I think
we're going to move to this
having a whole nother level of
interfacing with this machine with
language and
that's very very powerful we'll just go
through the whole thing it's like
take X
and the
language interface to it that's really
powerful
what are you hoping to use AIS for
over the next
six to 12 months
first of all I generate I post a AI
picture every day and a half bin when
did you switch from manual to last June
almost a year ago
and
which tools do you mostly use I tend to
go to Mid Journey still
mid-journey for those that don't has a
very curious interface it's a Discord
Channel yeah and at first I was
completely Bamboozled and infuriated
with that but I came to see it as genius
why is that because everybody's working
in the open it's like the ultimate
learning vehicle you and I learned
something every time I go being a
student in the surgery theater exactly
you're seeing how other people do it
it's not behind closed doors they're
doing it in public and oh my gosh do you
learn so much that way so fast
and what's interesting the year before
that I did a piece of art every day on
my iPad with procreate
and I spent almost as much time
on the AIS making an image as I do when
I make it myself
because again the accusation among the
painters in the 1800s when the
photography came along was oh you guys
you you just push the button
and we realized of course now that
photography is not just pushing the
button there's a lot more involved in
making a really great photograph than
just pushing the button you have to be
right position all this kind of stuff
and the same thing with with the air
it's all you're just clicking no no it's
like it's like photography I feel I have
some of the same kind of a stance that I
have and I'm photographing I'm kind of
hunting I'm searching through it I'm
trying to find a good position a good
area where there's kind of promise and
I'm moving around and I'm trying and I'm
whispering to the AI how about this I'm
changing the word order I'm actually
interacting having a conversation with
it over time it may take a half hour or
more to get an image that I'm happy with
and I'm at that point very comfortable
in putting my name as a co-creator of it
because I have mean the intern have
worked together to make this thing
okay so you have the art application any
other application in the next six months
well I'm actually using the chat Bots to
help write chat Bots
you know Bing stuff and Google for me
I've always had problems making the
first draft it's just a killer yeah and
I know the feeling you know the feeling
I find it helpful in making the first
draft how do you prompt it what would be
an example approach
all different ways and and that's I've
been collecting this and and here's the
thing in your book of spells yes here
here's the thing about it is that this
is an important lesson about technology
is that we have to use it to figure it
out
there's something I call thinkism which
is this Reliance on trying to solve
problems by thinking about them which is
very appealing to people who like to
think okay and you can only go so far
with thinkism because all the things
we're discovering about this none of the
inventors of this had any idea that they
could be used this way that's cool right
and so we're discovering we collectively
by using it or discovering its
capabilities and eventually its Harms
but that's important because this is how
we steer the things and so the problem
with trying to prohibit or turn it off
or ban it is that you don't get to steer
van going back to the metaphor so right
now through use we're uncovering all
these things and I've been trying to
track how people are actually using them
and like for instance chat so here's the
thing these chat models basically what
they generate are wisdom of the crowd
kind of knowledge the wisdom of the
crowd was very famous counting the jelly
beans right like if you average all the
attempts by humans to count the number
of jelly beans in a bottle
the best guest the most accurate was
kind of like the average of them and
that's what we're getting with the chat
it's taking everything is written the
plus and the minuses the Geniuses and
the jerks and it's averaging out and
that's what's giving you is kind of an
average so most of the content generated
by the chats is sort of broadly correct
very kind of average very kind of bland
and a lot of what you're doing with the
intern
is kind of pressing them so one of the
tricks is that you said you can ask for
it to be a little bit snarkier or more
professional so let's say you're
starting
tabula rasa
idea popped into your head in the shower
okay I want to give a rough draft a shot
what is the step number one step number
two so it depends I might I might ask
you to do a summary of what's known
about this tell me everything that knows
about it write a first draft with
bullets those are the five bullet points
could you give a real example an example
you might use I'm trying to think of the
last one I did how Egyptians influenced
Roman architecture I don't know exactly
right you could do that give me the five
bullet points of stuff and then you
could say you could have questions about
some parts you didn't understand or like
expand this bullet one citing more
sources or give me an example of a day
in the life for this or 10 more examples
of how this might play out you could
kind of expand it that way you could
also shrink it in terms of like
summarizing making bullet points or
what's the key takeaway or how about if
I wanted to have like a teachable moment
out of this and so you would have all
these kinds of things floating around
and then again it's the internet work
it's like good but you're not going to
use it you're probably rewriting it it's
maybe give me some ideas I didn't have
or maybe the structure of how it
organized it was that's pretty good for
four of them and so it's a start and for
me it gets you past the breath hold of
the empty bridge for me this is really
big it's just getting going and then you
can also use it later on
I have a friend who writes scripts and
they do show me all the weak plot points
in this
or could you explain that you put the
script in and they'll say what are some
of the contradictory platforms that's a
great use right just you know kind of
like thinking about my fiction you can
find internal inconsistency internal
consistencies or where is continuity
broken or things like that
here's something I used my book which
we'll get to
my publisher asked for talking points
[Music]
talking so I said make a list of nine
talking points for this machine number
one for this book woolly mammoth number
two I'm kidding and it made it a good
list again I couldn't really use the
list but it was I could use it to make
the list the starting point it was a
starting point and here's another thing
so I have a friend who has a Blog a
daily blog they generate
40 posts a day
okay I can probably guess who yes it is
I was like that's a lot it's 40 a day so
they use it to help write headlines
they'll give a thing and say give me
five headlines now I've actually not
used say Chad GPT for this there's an
upload function where you can upload
your document and then use that as the
basis or part of the basis for the
prompt yeah write some headlines it says
it's really really good with suggesting
something that they hadn't thought of or
he said also sometimes I'll give it the
the little the posting it said give me a
great punch line at the end
that's cool and again it's the intern
you know they're bad you know pretty
good it's going to give you something
though give you something to start with
you know I'll give you an example from
my own life just for fun A friend of
mine suggested this because he sent me a
text he said this is pretty interesting
and he used chat GPT he's been exploring
all these tools in great depth and I've
played with a lot of them but not in the
depth that he has and he had suggested a
podcast guest
John verakee who was on not too long ago
and he simply put in a prompt along the
lines of
what are questions that Tim Ferriss
might ask John verveighkey on his
podcast in the style of Tim Ferriss and
they weren't perfectly Polished but they
were not bad right exactly and not bad
is I think the title I mean if that's
what we were talking about it's a not
bad intern okay it's still not bad
interns Universal not bad personal
intern and you know they'll get better
and I think we'll also again they'll get
specialized
so
in 15 years
15 years
so here's my reluctance about that I saw
VR for the first time
Jared Lanier in
1989 87.
I
could see that in five years I could see
like
I mean it was so good it was so amazing
we'll be at Ready Player One in 1992
exactly
so what's happened in the 30 years since
then
the state of the Oculus whatever is
about the same as what I saw was
geraldinear
but it's a million times cheaper right
right okay but it really isn't a million
times better
so
I don't know I I think this is the time
for scenarios I think I could have a
different bunch of different scenarios
rather than making a prediction sure
right and you know one of the scenarios
is that it doesn't get exponentially
better but it just gets exponentially
pervasive
which you would think would automatic
not automatically it's a strong word
would make it better in terms of yeah
access to larger data sets and yeah
again I think one of the things that
might come we might have a much more
tailored version of this all right so
going back to the you know like your
attempts to
to train it on your own stuff or to
maybe have a more customized version of
stuff that you want so it's maybe
relatively the same level but it's much
more personalized and tailored and
customized to what you do and how you do
it and also also tailored for my
audience I want to and I've already seen
a few people do this because my
transcripts are available on the website
I want to train
an AI on my transcripts and also a lot
of materials that I produce so that the
most common questions I get right can be
sourced from actual answers I've given
I have a doctor friend who runs a
popular pediatrician site ask the doctor
these questions and he has trained it on
all his 20 years of answering questions
to his patients to do a chat
and it works pretty good yeah and it's
as I say better than no doctor yeah and
that's just on his is literally just
trained on his replies and I I think
more of that will be coming even better
so whether we get to the point where we
can do the deductive reasoning of the
transfer learning I don't know because
we haven't really seen that much so
that's one scenario is we suddenly make
another big innovation leap and we have
another
besides just being able to synthesize
pattern stuff we can actually do these
other kinds of cognition that would be
huge but there's no evidence that that's
going on
so another scenario is just that we have
more of this at a larger scale more
pervasive more tailorized kind of like
in the way that I don't know there's
probably been no real advances in social
media in the 10 years it's been around
all right
excellent advice for living
damn it Kevin I've been trying to get
you to talk about this and you keep
pushing back I was going to segue to
this because you mentioned using AI to
think differently right as a catalyst
for thinking differently and it made me
think of
advice that I've certainly read of yours
and you've probably we've had probably
had conversations about it which related
to Career advice for people say in their
20s and exploring Avenues
and creating for themselves or
attempting to create for themselves jobs
and activities that don't have clear
labels
and
using that among other tools as a way to
learn to think differently but let's
zoom out
so I'm holding two copies of the book
one is very very tiny this is a prized
position now I've read it probably 12
times I have many many notes and there
are all sorts of notes in here excellent
advice for living
now the tiny version I have says seeds
for contemplation which I also like and
then there's the very beautiful
cover of this Galley that you handed to
me just before we start recording
excellent advice for living wisdom I
wish I'd known earlier
how did this come to be what is the
Genesis story
I would write down
bits of
advice that to help me change my own
behavior
I'd like to kind of reduce something
that I could say to myself
to repeat to myself to remember
something
and as a way of changing my behavior and
and that kind of encapsulation and
reduction to a little tiny sentence for
me it was like a handle to grab hold of
it and bring it forth when I needed it
and an example would be if I know I had
something in my household and I can't
find it then when I finally do find it
I'd say to myself when I'm getting ready
to put it back don't put it back where I
found it put it back where I first
looked for it okay so I had my
flashlight
put it back where you first look for it
and I'm reminding myself that and so I
would start to write things down like
another one would be
if I'm invited to do a talk go meet
somebody or have coffee whatever it is I
would say to myself would I do this if
it was tomorrow morning it was this kind
of a filter to really make sure it
passed that hurdle because eventually it
will be tomorrow morning I have to think
about it and so I would say I got this
invite oh that's kind of interesting
good would I do this tomorrow morning so
this kind of making it into some
portable way that I could remind myself
very easily and I start getting the
habit of writing these down and I
realized a lot of it was sort of
advice that I wish I had known earlier
I have three kids and the way of our
parenting was the opposite of helicopter
parenting was very hands-off and I we
did not give them much advice ever
when I was growing up
I didn't really pay attention to what my
parents said I paid attention to what
they did and I figured that's what our
kids were doing too so we try to Model
Behavior rather than to say it so
neither my wife or I or
ever really gave much advice
but I thought that now that I was
writing it down that I should give them
advice so I began this idea of trying to
extract out and put into a little handle
something encapsulated that I could give
to my kids
and I did a bunch when I was 68 on my
birthday I kind of released it to him to
my son at that time who was a young
adult just becoming an adult and
a lot of people loved it and it shade
around the internet I did it for a
couple more years and I realized that
had a lot to say
I was finally giving advice it was
keeping to myself
but it's kind of scattered around the
internet and I thought it was really
handy to have it in a book so I made a
prototype myself just made a little book
I made five copies and I sent it around
to see if it was kind of worked as a
book and this book also has my little
Doodles in it and it worked and so I
sent it to a publisher they loved it
they didn't like the Doodles and so
it said no art by you
okay
[Laughter]
it's in a portable form and actually I
realized afterwards although I it was
not in my head at the time but it's very
tweetable
it's just very tweetable these are
tweets and so they work at the kind of
attention span of a young person these
days
and they they transmit well so the
version you have here has about another
100 that aren't even in this oh look at
this
just when I thought
Christmas was far away I tried to make
them as practical as possible actionable
not conventional
positive if at all possible
and short
so
you can find no better medicine for your
family than regular meals together
without screens let me throw a few out
just because I have so many notes in
here so I'll mention a couple
and one that I I may not get verbatim
but I've thought quite a bit about
because when I look back at all the
places I've spent time it's totally true
it's something like if
if an outdoor patio is less than six
feet wide no one will ever use it no one
will use the balcony listen never never
and I thought about it I was like that
100 maps to all of my experience
you have what you do on your bad days
matters more than what you do on your
good days you know this is also overlaps
with a lot of my thoughts on on ritual
and routine versus
relying on say discipline greatness is
incompatible with optimizing in the
short term and it goes on and on I'm
just mentioning a few that I've
highlighted for myself you don't marry a
person you marry a family
that's a big one I decided you don't
marry a family you marry country because
my wife is so much different country
and you know who knows maybe 100 years
from now you don't marry a person you
marry species
if you can't tell what you desperately
need it's probably sleep
don't aim to have others like you aim to
have them respect you which which also
helps in saying no to things you
wouldn't want to do tomorrow morning are
there any that come to mind for you here
at is yeah balcony or porch needs to be
at least six feet deep or it won't be
used then there are some very very
specific recommendations learn to tie a
bowline knot and practice in the dark
with one hand for the rest of your life
you'll use this not more times than you
could ever believe true yeah I only
learned that not I want to say in 2012
and I've used it a million times since
what are some here
that people have responded particularly
well to are there are there any that pop
out that come to mind
I'll buy you some time when you feel
pressure to pick a choice don't forget
the choice of not choosing any that's
when I start for myself one thing that
has surprised me is that there's been no
overlap in people's favorites okay
no overlaps in people's favorites I
don't know what to make of that but
anyway that's what it is so I'll tell
you some of my favorites
when you're in your 20s you should
spend a little bit of time doing
something that's sort of crazy insane
unprofitable
unorthodox orthogonal
because
that's going to be your Touchstone and
the foundation of your success later on
try and deliberately don't try for
something successful or career do
something very very strange and weird
it's kind of like to the other bit of
advice of like the thing that made you
weird as a kid can make you great as an
adult if you don't lose it yeah I mean
this is like it's true so one of my my
favorite bits of advice that can be
expanded which is don't aim to be the
best be the only yeah category one
here's the category of one right before
us you are living that like even you
know 10 years ago I don't know when you
started your podcast but if almost 10
I'll be 10 years next year you want to
be doing something where it's hard to
explain to your mother what it is that
you do right so I was like what is it
well it's not quite radio you know I
don't know it's like talking and so
that's where you want to be you want to
be the only and that's a very high bar
because it requires a tremendous amount
of self knowledge and awareness to get
to that point to really understand what
it is that you do better than anybody
else in the world and for most of us it
takes Our Lives to to figure that out
and we also by the way need
family friends colleges customers
clients everyone around us to help us
understand what it is that we do better
than any Wells because because we can't
really get there by yourself you can't
do thinkism you can't think your way
there you have to try and live it out
and that's why most people's remarkable
lives are full of detours and dead ends
and right turns because it's a very high
bar but if you can get there
you don't need a resume there's there's
no competition and it's easy for you
because it's yeah you're doing it you're
not looking over your shoulder or you're
just right there so
don't aim to be the best be the only
on the easy front a question that I've
sometimes asked my friends because the
things that are right in front of us all
the time are sometimes the hardest to
see there you go is what do you think is
easy for me that is harder for other
people right because sometimes you take
I shouldn't say oftentimes take it for
granted because it's just what you do
yeah and you don't even see where you
have something that falls into that
actually
used that in a similar form of the
question at dinner parties when I'm
sitting next to buddy so one of my bits
of advice is that
almost everybody knows a lot more about
something than anybody else around them
and so I always sit down it's like what
do you know more about than most people
and I feel it's like my job to kind of
find out what that is and it's not
obvious yeah it's not always obvious you
kind of have to work at it but it's
always amazing yeah totally if you can
get there they know something they'll
just blow your mind yeah and
so that's my assignment when I go to a
party is like that person knows an
amazing amount of something but it's not
going to be obvious but they'll tell me
I have a close cousin of that that I
sometimes use myself which is once once
someone has shared or maybe it's already
known what they do professionally their
primary gig let's just say it's Finance
in some capacity and I might just ask
could be anything though it doesn't
matter yeah and I would just ask if you
had to give a TED Talk 20 minutes long
but it couldn't be on anything that
people at this table know you for
including Finance right what would it be
and you get some of the most out of left
feel responses and it opens the
floodgates to really interesting
conversation I'm gonna mention a couple
more all right your enjoyment of travel
is inversely proportional to the size of
your luggage this is 100 True of
backpacking it is liberating to realize
how little you really need and if people
are not familiar with our first
conversation they should listen to it
and they will realize that you walk the
walk with that
you have certainly walked the walk with
that and are minimalist in so many ways
I want to ask a follow-up question to
one of these for the best results with
your children I started this one spend
only half the money you think you should
double the time with them yeah
one of the
letters don't get a lot of physical
letters but one of the letters that I
most look forward to every year I think
it's your year review or Christmas
perhaps but you give a recap and you
talk about the family and Adventures and
so on
what have you found to be some of the
best investments of time with your kids
because
abstractly
I bet most parents would nod their heads
and say of course that makes sense
absolutely
but not always of spending time with
kids are equal I would imagine for
building intimacy
and a relationship with your kids
or maybe other things what have you
found to be really good uses of time
I don't know enough about this generally
but I can only tell you what we have
done ourselves and for me that's what
I'm asking yeah for me what I've seen is
a couple things one is making things
together
and I'm a maker and so I have to kind of
where he gives me better instincts to be
too involved or take over too much but
to really allow that kind of Cooperative
joint making together and it's fun for
the kid and it's fun for me and you get
to see
frustrations overcoming frustrations
making mistakes overcoming mistakes so
there's there's a tremendous amount
going on both them learning and me
learning about them and that
togetherness is really great what kind
of stuff have you made together we've
made Go Cards we've made gingerbread
castles we've made
styrobot I don't know if you're in my
office robot with my son making it was
made from recycled styrofoam
it's with nine feet tall
just you know art projects
helping in the garden
doing chores together
I would say travel is
undoubtedly one of the best learning
experiences so much that I think as a
nation we susceptionize travel but as a
family if you can afford it and I don't
mean that's like going on vacation I I
the kind of travel I like is where you
are learning it's kind of like a
learning experience as an experience
and oh my gosh does that so powerful and
I would say one thing about it they've
learned doing it and that is that I was
a little concerned when we were doing
very intense travel with my kids at a
younger age
they kind of at times
didn't seem to be paying attention it
seemed not to be aware or they were kind
of maybe
wanting to stay in their hotel and play
cards or things like that when they were
we were in Tibet you know whatever but
later on I found out the x-way they were
paying attention but they couldn't
process it at the time
so the experience were there and they
would reprocess it over time it would
become more and more valuable as they
had more and more to kind of interpret
it and that trip which I kind of thought
was a failure at the time because they
were sort of not really appreciating it
or actually grew in importance and so
don't be dismayed if you take your kids
on a great adventure and they're kind of
like not impressed or they're not
changed or whatever no no no they
haven't yet been able to process it and
they'll process it over time any other
tips for traveling with kids because I
can imagine
a family trip yeah and it is almost
certainly very different from
like Kevin Kelly family trip where a
family has gone to five countries
they've stated the Four Seasons in each
one the kids have been on their phones
the entire time and you can film the
rest of the pictures so what would be
perhaps some recommendations I'm not
saying people should sleep on the
sidewalks just you can travel and not
actually leave the comfort of your own
usual scaffolding yeah no it's one of
the bits of advice is that you know like
a vacation plus a disastrous equals an
adventure you know so like one of the
times I rode my bicycle across the US
was from Vancouver down to Mexico on the
coast and I rode with my son who was a
teenager and I had his nephew who's a
teenager alone that was an incredible
experience and
doing that together kind of like an
adventure together was tremendous for
them because it took them out of the San
Francisco bubble and you can see the
real world and again was
a learning experience about overcoming
you know doing things that seemed hard
but turned out to be things you just
could do
so
I would say yes
try new things another thing that I
think is really good for travel is
to
to almost go somewhere at random
I mean literally like their policy for
our family was to follow passions and
interests rather than destinations so
every kid would have a we would say
we're gonna follow your passion for our
vacation this year whatever you're
interested in you know if you are
interested in Anne of Green Gables okay
we're going to go to Nova Scotia and
visit all the Anna Green Gables sites
what is Anne of Green Gables Gables is a
popular
children's or young adults story I say
Anna Green Gables and and there's a
series of books and it was based in Nova
Scotia and there's kind of a big
following about that got it
Arkansas was interested in dinosaurs
when he's very little okay we're gonna
go to all the dinosaur digs and dinosaur
museums and dinosaur excavations that we
can find and that was the theme and they
were very engaged in that vacation we
were in we were in an RV and we were
going around visiting dinosaurs because
that child got to pick
the follow question I had after the the
bicycle story was
whether your kids have always been game
for these Adventures
or whether you've
cultivated slash Jedi Mind tricked them
into being more game because I I would
have to imagine this speculation but
their parents listening are like I could
never convince my teenage son to go
cycling for weeks at a time or months at
a time whatever it might be maybe that's
just out of the box yeah and then ready
to go I guess I would say it was not an
issue that we had they were up for
particularly again if you have something
that's
surrounding their own passions I was
imagining that if you've folded them
into the process of making these
decisions from an early age right they
relate to these things differently than
if everything has been an assignment
right I think that's how you do it we
homeschooled our son for one year and
part of that home year of homeschooling
we weren't home we were traveling and
again it was this idea of
where would you like to go you get to
kind of set
some of the things and that was total
engagement right yeah you're invested
yeah you're invested all right I'm gonna
grab a few more here if an elementary
school student
is struggling first thing check their
eyesight for advice something I need to
get checked my family has quite a bit of
glaucoma and intraocular pressure issues
and I haven't had them checked in a long
time so I'll get there purchase the most
recent tourist guidebook to your
hometown or region you'll learn a lot by
playing the tourist once a year this is
something I did I went out and I
actually I actually got the guy books
and you do pick up a lot yeah you pick
up a lot I did this in San Francisco too
it's shocking how much you miss I
remember growing up in New York I never
made it to the Statue of Liberty or the
Empire State Building until a German
friend visited me like 10 years ago and
was shocked that I had never been to
either of these things and I was like
you know maybe I should at least spend
an afternoon and go see these things and
it was a blast one Thanksgiving Day we
went into San Francisco and rode the
cable cars which we had never been on
yeah and it was the perfect day because
there was nobody else on them it was
Thanksgiving Day and so yes it's a way
of again I favor things to help you
learn
giving you experience and
treating your own neighborhood is is a
great way to do that
so I'm giving some more examples I could
keep going because there's so many good
ones but I'll give an example of Highly
tactical and specific all right to
Signal an emergency use the rule of
three three shots three hornblaster
three whistles right and then you have
the more I would say still practical but
conceptual when you're stuck explain
your problem to others often simply
laying out a problem will present a
solution make quote unquote explaining
the problem part of your troubleshooting
process yeah and I wish I knew that so
much earlier I would not have been able
to write the four hour work week had I
not taken this advice I was totally
stuck on an entire section
I was roadblocked couldn't make any
progress I was really starting to panic
and a writer friend of mine said just
have someone interview you about why
you're having trouble and record it and
I did that I had somebody who was
a Ghostwriter I didn't I've never used a
Ghostwriter but she knew how to ask
questions
recorded the conversation didn't even
need the recording because it helped me
walk right through it and by the end I
knew what the solution was problem
solved yeah well I have an assistant and
when I get stuck I'll start to explain
to her my thing and then
by the end it's like wait a minute I get
it what I was like I didn't need you but
actually I didn't need you just to to
walk you through it yeah yeah
I'm gonna ask you the same question I
asked about the is it the silver quarter
the silver chord I just wanted to make
sure I was adding the article or not so
the silver cord what would you hope this
to do
what would be success for you or is it
already successful you're like ah I've
done it generally my books have an
audience of one you know I did this big
Asia book yeah 30 pounds three volumes
spectacularly beautiful gorgeous
gorgeous gorgeous book you know 9000
images there was no one you took
everyone I took every wrote Every
caption I did all the layout every
there's a thousand pages each one has a
different design I did the whole thing
and
there's nobody who enjoys that book more
than me just going through it of course
I was there but I made up one prototype
book like this book here is a prototype
and all I wanted was one book if there
was no other books made I would have
been happy but since I was making one
it's so easy to make others so it's like
if I can share it with you send it to my
friends that makes me even happier so
the success for that was having the book
this one
is not so much for me
it is if other people are also can gain
and find ways to repeat these things and
improve their lives that is success for
me so I would hope that a young person
like me
would hear some of this advice and be
able to
encapsulate it and repeat it to
themselves and make their lives better
and that would be a success for me
I'm gonna take a slight detour because
that is my want I'm gonna take a slight
detour
because
this is on my mind
do you still recommend sabbaticals oh my
gosh
how would you suggest maybe for people
who have not heard our prior
conversations
think about sabbaticals the value of how
to actually take a sabbatical what does
that mean no I'm a huge fan of
sabbaticals and I think I had some
advice in the book I put it that
I think we
over emphasize
our productivity and efficiency but
there's the most powerful thing you can
do for the productivity
is to the best thing for your work ethic
is to have a rest Yes actually that's
one I've started something along the
lines of the key to a great work ethic
is having a great rest ethic so this
idea of I think goofing off
wasting time
sabbatical sabbaths taking a Sabbath
are all essential to to the creative
life they're just they're just
absolutely it's almost like sleep
you just have to do it and it does it by
re rejuvenating you and shifting your
perspective
by releasing you from I mean there's
just so many things that it works on
and most I think
for me my own experience is the the best
things I've done
came after you know taking shifting it's
like the clutch when you're shifting you
want to put the clutch in right
otherwise you just kind of grind so I
think it's really valuable and and again
not just like every seven years which is
a technical sabbatical but like Sabbath
it's like vacations
but more importantly
time off and goofing off and I think I
find that the young people believe it or
not the ones that I am associated with
don't Goof Off enough they go right from
college
in their first job and that's like
no yeah
there were people that wired they came
right from college and after seven years
they were still there it's like
I sit down like why are you here
you should not be here when was the last
time you goofed off or wasted time yeah
yeah and so
no I'm a big believer so imagine the
rest of management must love that I was
the management no were you the only
management we don't have to be labor the
point
why did some people quit last week
so I think it's essential and so the
your question of like well
this is why I love you it's like yeah
give me some practical stuff about how
to take a sabbatical
or just what might it look like right
say for for someone who I mean let's
personalize it like for me yeah what
might a sabbatical look like what would
you consider the sort of minimal viable
duration and like what would make it a
sabbatical versus me just being in a
foreign Locale thinking about the usual
stuff so it's interesting because my
wife's both of her companies she'd been
at she was at Genesect for 30 years and
she said 23andMe now
had a sabbatical program
an official one it was six weeks every
six years which is basically a European
Vacation yeah right an annual vacation
so
I think six weeks is probably like to me
like the minimum for a sabbatical but
man it could be very effective in six
weeks
for me like doing art is something I
like
you know in the old days you used to
have to like professors would get
sabbaticals and they would do their own
project that they were working on or go
to a school somewhere or have a visiting
appointment
you know travel is a very very common
one
for you
I think you know your effort right now
to to work in animation and stuff
I guess the general pattern is you want
something that's different in the
structure and Rhythm from what you
normally do and so our Temptation those
of us who like to make things is to make
something different but that's not
really
sabbatical we're kind of in the same
Rhythm we're learning and so it's sort
of like you want to go in a different
direction and
I did this about it for once where I
just read books and it was like
literally that's all I'm gonna do I'm
gonna get up in the morning I'm gonna
read books
and I'm not going to do anything else
and that was really different from my
normal behavior
but incredibly powerful and by the end I
just had I went to travel because I had
it you know it's just like blue madagas
because it had to go but that sabbatical
of like only reading books and reading
books all day long and I could read
almost like about an average of a about
a book a day because some books are
really short and some were really long
but my the synapse associations that you
get from reading a book after book after
book you begin to think that it's
they're all talking to each other the
authors yeah you're just like they're
talking about the same thing they must
have known about each other you know
it's impossible but you have this sense
of this all knitting together yeah
saturation yeah so I think the the
recipe is to have a different Rhythm and
a different mode than you normally have
you know for you that might be something
like
I'm also used to making making yeah it
could be interesting for me just to
Shadow somebody for a period of time
right somebody who's really good in the
world of say animation using that
example and just watch like I'm not
allowed actually there you go to make I
like that anything for a while I just
have to watch
that would actually be very challenging
it would be that's right yeah it's like
you have to watch somebody but I do that
every evening on YouTube
and again I could rant about YouTube
forever because I think it's way
underrated for an influence story I'm
not gonna name names yeah
actually I can I can name one name but I
don't want to mention all the names so
mutual friend Matt Mullen right we were
just spending time together and he said
you went out on a walk with one of his
friends yeah and you the two of you just
talked about YouTube for two hours
straight yes
so why don't you expand a little bit
what do you do on YouTube I watch no no
no I'm sorry so thank God you do it has
videos Tim yeah no I watch people work
you watch people work yeah I watch
people making things
like what like people restoring cars
people making boats people making clay
things people making just watching
people make things
because I'm a maker and because I
learned so much by watching people work
much more than you ever learn in a book
and are these just full capture videos
or are they giving commentary as they go
are they just a kind of a peek over the
shoulder as they do their thing all the
above all right all the above sometimes
your time lapses them just in the shop
sometimes you're giving lessons
sometimes they're showing a technique
sometimes they're walking through it
some record their mistakes some don't
I mean I subscribe to so many that
like it's hard to generalize but the
point is is that why I think it's
underappreciated is that it's an
accelerant on the learning the process
of people discovering something putting
it up
other people other makers watching it
saying oh that's a good idea it's like
your visual Discord modifying it putting
their version up and then two days later
someone else has improved it and brain
surgeons are using this right now we're
a brain surgeon will have an operation
they'll be filming their operation they
have a little bit of a technique
Improvement that they'll watch other
brain surgeons are watching brain
surgeons on YouTube on YouTube and
within days they'll have an improvement
and it's going this fast unlike years
and years of waiting to a paper being
published in the paper it's like how can
you do that so so it's this incredible
accelerant and the problem not the
problem but the thing about YouTube is
all invisible it's not like a bookstore
where you see what's there you have no
idea that this is happening and it's
like it's tremendous it's all being in
the libraries of Alexandria with a
blindfold on exactly you're only allowed
to take it off once you grab something
little tiny people oh there's some books
there about astronomy but nowhere is
like this huge world but anyway I liked
your idea of watching
people execute at work and not having to
produce them that would be a tremendous
sabbatical or true sabbatical yeah it
would also be such a shift for me
because so much of what I do is virtual
or on a screen doing it say via YouTube
would not be much of a behavioral shift
right and
doing it in person
I also travel and move around so much
being in say a fixed location
would be a very different experience
right I was thinking productivity
there's one little bit of advice
actually it was telling us to David
Allen of all people
who was the get things done guys of
course
there is a tendency
the normal approach to kind of like
organizing your life is that you want to
kind of like be productive so you want
to get through the things that you need
done the most productive way in the
least time is possible
but I find it's better to kind of shift
over to say what are the kinds of things
I want to do they want to spend as much
time as possible doing
that to me is the focus is to shift from
minimizing the amount of time on things
but to maximize the amount of time to do
things that you don't ever want to stop
doing where you want to maximize the
time right that was one
I'm not going to go through all the
pages to find it but that was actually
one I had my thumb on literally that I
was going to bring up because that is a
piece of advice in the book I have to
ask because I've never been able to
figure it out probably because I haven't
asked you specifically why are you so
you're like the David Hasselhoff is to
Germany what you are to China like
you're huge and shy what is the reason
for that it was an accident it was an
accident so I wrote a book
out of control in the early 90s that was
ignored in the US it was way too early
it was just too early it was talking
about the centralized system that whole
chapter on crypto in 1994 that actually
that I gave to Stephen Levy and signed
him to follow up and he later wrote the
book on the crypto stuff
crypto not being the money but mine was
about digital money and so
it was just too early
but it was translated into Chinese at
the beginning of the Arts right now 2006
maybe five I don't remember exactly and
it was actually crowdsourced translated
which was even more interesting okay
because there was so much Demand by
it was just some fans in China basically
that's a task
it was crowdsourced yeah I get it but
crowds it's still attached yeah so there
was one guy and I owe it all to one guy
who was a real true fan and he organized
the crowdsourcing translation of it and
it came out at the right the moment that
Jack Ma and Pony ma were beginning to
build their do their internet things and
it was hugely influential on them
and they talk about the book ah so every
entrepreneur in China has to read the
book because Jack ma right recommended
it right Steve Jobs of China he's
talking about it right
and that's primarily why it kind of
disseminated from that and then all my
other things were translated and
I became the prophet of you know the
internet or something because I was
talking about these things yeah before
there was the things and so uh kind of
what profits do right and so in China
there is a little bit of a herd
mentality where people read it because
other people have been reading it and
need to read it happens here too but to
even to larger yeah and so
most of my fans are actually in China
wow and I still
was going there on a regular basis
giving talks about the future of X and Y
and the major difference there was that
they were actively listening
and then executing and doing the stuff
and they were so eager to to build and
to get ahead they would say you know we
were talking about whatever it is
blockchain whatever okay we're gonna
start doing blockchain it was like they
were absorbing it and actually acting
upon it rather than just kind of oh
that's a nice idea
they were really looking for things to
do
very proactive right so it had a huge
influence in that way
so you said you're known as KK yeah do
they write it in the English KK or is
they I'm sure they have a Chinese name
for you but there isn't characters it's
just that they can read the letters no
I'm sure I don't know but I mean it's
just KK I have a Chinese name what is
your Chinese name kaiwan kaibi that's a
great name yeah
that is a great name um you could
slightly change that and sell yourself
as a K-pop Star in the US it's all the
ranch you do really well right girl
cool older brother yeah right that's you
man that's that's how I think about you
well
is there any other
advice you would like to give or
anything else you'd like to say about
excellent advice for living
wisdom I wish I'd known earlier
or any other thoughts you would like to
share any closing comments requests of
my audience yes formal complaints you'd
like to Lodge anything at all
there is one little piece of advice at
the very end which maybe sums up
the assignment which is
kind of your goal in life is to be able
to say on the day before you die that
you fully become yourself so I'm really
want to emphasize this idea of fully
becoming yourself and the difficulty in
the challenge that is to to discover
what that is
but how powerful that is and that's true
whether you're making you know starting
a company or becoming a an artist or a
teacher whatever it is and
the reason why I'm very Pro on
technology is I think it enables us
helps us generally
to become more of ourselves that we all
have mixtures of talents in in us that
actually need external tools to help us
express things and so I am interested in
kind of increasing that pool possible
tools in the world so that all of us
would have some chance to really
expressing your Genius and fully
becoming ourselves and you know that
includes like having clean water and
education and access to
Transportation those are all the
fundamental Tools in addition to the
kind of high-tech stuff but I really do
believe that all of us have a unique
genius I mean every evidence I've seen
in the world and people around the world
suggest that that's true and so
if I can at all unleash
people to
attempt
to fulfill their best self to be more of
themselves to be fully them
then that would be a success for me
Kevin's so nice to spend time with you
so much fun always this it always is Tim
you make me happy I just love your
sincerity thank you you too man thanks
so much and I have read my little
bootleg copy of excellent advice for
living probably 20 times it really is
something that you can refer to again
and again and again and each time you
read it
with a new pair of eyes because you're
in a different state maybe a different
place in your life you also glean
different things so I really
can't recommend this book enough it's so
easy to read excellent advice for living
wisdom I wish I'd known earlier Kevin
Kelly go get it folks you will not be
sorry you will thank me later and
you can be found on Twitter
the tool of the profit at Kevin to Kelly
and on the website certainly kk.org
where people can also find one thousand
true fans which everyone should read
and
for those listening we will have links
to everything in the show notes as per
usual Tim dot Blog podcast until next
time be just a little Kinder than is
necessary to not just other people but
yourself and strive to become fully
yourself
and tools are part of that advice is
certainly a part of that and maybe a
combination is part of that so until
next time thanks for tuning in